[Applause]
thank you
you look like a princess you look so
pretty here hi there
nice to see you I don't know if I've
ever seen you look as beautiful as you
do right it's because I'm here with you
oh
with your mail I know I know okay so fun
fact I'm doing
um celebrity IOU which is a show
um that the Property Brothers do uh
Jonathan and Drew Scott obviously and um
so I've been hanging out with your man I
know he's having so much fun with you
they love you
but I have to just tell you I've been
waiting to tell you and I thought maybe
I should do it in front of everybody
because you know that's so intimate the
way that your man speaks about you
and the way he speaks about your family
oh like I've got to get home for for
dinner I need to be there every night
this is what we do this is how we do it
my kids my woman our home our family
yeah he's so sweet I'm very lucky it's
like the best and he is a great family
too the dreams dreams okay you guys met
on carpool karaoke so like when you went
to work that day
did I know no did you know your whole
life was gonna change no I didn't I I
just couldn't believe like he was so
nice
like I went to say hi to him and I
hadn't met him before but he had like he
had messaged me on Instagram just saying
oh I'm looking forward to meeting you
and then I went to yes but it's nice but
he's just nice like that right so I went
to meet them and I was like I can't
believe he's so nice
she's like the nicest person you know
people just aren't that nice generally
he's just so nice like I've been we've
been together for like over three years
and he's still that nice
he goes over and like fixes stuff at my
parents house he's so nice he really is
and you deserve that thank you that's
right you do I'm so glad that you guys
found it I try to be a nice back too
I love you so much I just assume like
you you are a nice person you are kind
you are delightful like you're the girl
that people put in films and television
because you're the ideal girl so we all
know that about you and assume you're a
good person and I know you're nice too
thank you you deserve a nice fella I
have an idea what data Canadian
I married a Canadian
okay we've both been impersonated uh on
on Saturday Night Live yeah
um you were there
with your impersonation so you knew it
was happening yep what did you think
when you were watching Abby Elliot
impersonate you
I mean I love it I was so happy you know
what I mean it's so flattering I was
like oh my gosh I've made it well as
long as we could laugh yeah I'm so I was
so happy okay you're in a dress
literally that could not be more perfect
for this question you used to dress up
as a princess to do homework may I ask
why and should I be doing this with my
daughters of course well I mean if they
like if they're into princesses I think
it's fun because I was like it was
actually I always like to dress up but I
actually remember it most in high school
because it was I would have like four
hours of homework every night so you did
this in high school yeah oh yeah okay I
pictured it way younger and now I love
it even more
no I remember like I put on a big dress
and a tiara I found the picture I have
to find it I found myself sitting like
in a pile of textbooks
with like typing on my computer with my
tiara
princess dress I mean how has Jonathan
Scott not going to follow
like please come on okay so you're back
on a show
um that is very beloved it's in season
three that's how you know it's a hit on
Apple TV physical yeah tell me about
this
yes so uh I haven't started yet I just
kind of signed on so I'm really excited
I play like a sitcom star turn Fitness
enthusiast
I'm a fitness Enthusiast I mean I love
yeah I mean I like to I do like you know
like bar classes and stuff keep it tight
gotta keep it tight yeah I love it yeah
yeah I love the dance thing too me too
so growing up I dance every I took dance
class like every day so it's I still
just love that I cannot wait to see you
in the show I love everything you do I
mean you're just I've been so sweet
thank you thank you I love you so much
by the way is it true that you're gonna
teach me something about cooking with
oats yeah it's not even cooking it's
like easier than cooking will you teach
me I'll teach you
[Music]